this isn't Calais where tensions with
migrants are well-established we Stremme
is a sleepy fishing port four hours to
the west but it has three fairies a day
to England and that's why these young
men are here this isn't a one-off on
every track that passes through there
mostly from Sudan and almost all that
like teenagers on the edge of town they
sleep in the ditches the police remove
any tents they try to pitch every
morning they wait for the trucks to
arrive we follow one Bulgarian lorry the
first group manages to open the door but
none of them climb on a little further
on the driver stops he's clearly aware
of what's just happened some of the
truck guys who were trying to get on the
truck already making their way up here
and seconds later even before we were
back in the car they were past us and
onto the truck
the route down to the port here is not
like larger ports Calais or Dunkirk
where motorways lead straight to the
dockside here the trucks must snake
through the town it makes them much more
vulnerable to this the police do what
they can with the resources they have
around our car the young men don't like
being filmed
so even right in front of the police
there they're trying to go on
in all we counted 18 young men get on
most got off again but for maybe five it
was hard to see made it to the port
entrance there where every truck is
checked for were discovered we can't be
sure but it's possible one remained
inside a little later a few of them
agreed to talk to us you know 16 and
year 17 and you 60 16 14 14 okay and
you're all from Sudan why England
how do you know England your brother is
in England yeah and how did he get to
England on the trucks yeah he was here
and he told you to come to come here
yeah we watch another trucks - to the
port and then in exchange with some
locals in a moment which demonstrates a
divided over migration that stretches
across this continent see me Sonia books
a more feasible visage madam will serve
a vascular specific so as they keep
talking it's quite clear that this is
causing real real tensions within this
community and you can see the migrants
are continuing to gather as they do
every day and every night all across
this village they're not being helped by
anyone but volunteers nor are they being
sent home they're in a miserable
dangerous limbo and driven by that basic
human instinct that there must be
something better over the horizon
Mark Stone skynews in northern France